I want to take a minute here to insert some
factual basis into the this information that
is being spread very quickly about Donald
Trump's supposedly brilliant economy.
And today I'm not sure
[inaudible] argue with you about economic
lag times and when you attribute an economy
to one president versus the previous versus
the next, not going to argue about whether
the stock market is a good indicator of how
the economy is doing overall.
It's not.
We've talked about that before.
That's just not today's topic today.
The topic is simply to compare Obama and Trump
on three metrics, the stock market, jobs and
income.
First, let's do income.
Since we have new data there, since Donald
Trump took office, income growth has slowed
down compared to the Obama administration
incomes grew 5.8% from 2014 to 2016 under
Barack Obama.
And then when Donald Trump took over from,
uh, a 2016 to 2018 incomes grew at about half
of that rate.
Now, why don't we have 2019 data yet?
Well, it's not a trick.
People's taxes just haven't been done yet.
Peep taxes aren't due until April 15th or
even October if you take the extension.
So we just don't have the 2019 data yet.
Next, let's look at the stock market.
Looking at the S and P 500 the broadest of
the three major indices, you will see that
the S and P 500 gained more than 60% during
Barack Obama's first 37 months.
That's how long Trump's been president.
So we're comparing first 37 months of each
presidency, you would have gained 60% in the
S and P 500 during Barack Obama's first three
years plus one month while the S and P 500
has gained only 37% during Donald Trump's
first three years plus one month.
And then lastly on jobs, if you, we did this
in its own segment not long ago.
Um, the last three years of Obama's presidency
saw more than 8 million jobs created, whereas
the first three years of Trump's saw almost
20% smaller job growth, only 6.6 million jobs
created that is per the Bureau of labor statistics.
So when you put it all together, Obama was
better on income growth.
Income growth has slowed since Trump became
president.
Obama was better on the stock market.
When we compare Trump's, uh, full presidency
so far to the equivalent time period under
Barack Obama and Barack Obama was better on
job creation.
Was it that the recovery that Barack Obama
was overseeing was solely responsible for
this?
Well, that wouldn't really explain the job
growth at the end of Barack Obama's presidency.
So what you have to understand here is I am
not giving you this information to tell you
that there's nothing good happening in Trump's
economy.
There are people who have done well in Trump's
There's no question.
There are indicators that look okay in Trump's
economy, and I am not telling you this to
pretend that everything about Barack Obama's
economy was ginger snaps and waterfalls.
When we look at different indicators, we get
different results and for a lot of people,
the economy hasn't been good under Trump and
it wasn't good under Barack Obama.
The point is when they pick the metrics to
hang their hats on and we look at those metrics
and see that Trump is underperforming Obama,
you have to see the brazen and deceptive nature
of what they are trying to sell you.
The disinformation propaganda, I'm glad to
debate how do we really tell how an economy
is doing and it requires more than three metrics.
That's for sure.
And we've talked about that before, but what
we can't allow is not just for them to set
the narrative.
It's bad enough when they set the narrative,
but to set the narrative based on misleading
facts or things that are not actually factual.
That's the point of showing you this information.
Today.
I tweeted an image summarizing all of this,
uh, yesterday to my Twitter page D Pacman.
It's been retweeted a lot and we're doing
everything we can to spread that.
These are the numbers and the numbers don't
tell us anything.
It's sort of like if you accept that climate
change is happening, that doesn't tell us
what we have to do and what the policies should
be.
But if we have people who are still spreading
denialist conspiracy theories about climate
change, we're not even going to be able to
have the conversation about what should be
done.
Recognizing that stock growth has been slower
under Trump, recognizing that job growth has
been been lower under Trump.
It doesn't tell us what has to happen, but
we're starting with the facts and that's where
we should always be starting